[Musica]
avete mai visitato il sito del bayonne
institute come probabilmente saprete la
biomimesi all imitazione della natura
per risolvere problemi della vita reale
e ingegneri e ricercatori hanno messo a
disposizione proprio dall'istituto di
biomasse un database di soluzioni già
testate con successo dalla natura per
risolvere in maniera sostenibile
problemi concreti
vediamo alcuni esempi come progettare il
treno superveloce shinkansen che
sfreccia a 300 chilometri orari senza
che produca un rumore assordante
all'uscita di una galleria
c'è qualcuno in natura che riesce a
muoversi ad altissime velocità e
silenziosamente nonostante un improvviso
è molto forte cambio di pressione certo
il martin pescatore basta imitare la
forma areodinamica del suo becco che gli
consente di fiondarsi fine il suo sa
menti in acqua per catturare i pesci e
se volessi fare a meno di riscaldamento
e aria condizionata in un edificio come
li skate center di harare in zimbabwe
mantenendo la temperatura interna
costante al 31 gradi all'ingegneria
edile di quale piccolo animale mi dovrà
ispirare dalle termiti i loro terminali
che possono svilupparsi fino al 13 metri
in altezza e 40 in profondità debbono
mantenere una temperatura interna
costante di 31 gradi per consentire la
coltivazione del fungo di cui si nutre
la colonia tale fungo infatti non
sopravvivrebbe all'escursione termica di
40 gradi cagione notte a cui sono
sottoposti quotidianamente i nidi delle
termiche limitando lo stesso sistema di
apertura e chiusura dei canali di
areazione utilizzato dalle termiti sua
riuscita ad ottenere un effetto simile
agli space center
questi sono solo due esempi fantastici
di quanto la natura sia efficace
pensate al miracolo della vita una
sottile bolla d'aria l'acqua e il sole
forniscono il nutrimento alle piante che
sono alla base della maggior parte delle
catene alimentari
quando tutti gli organismi muoiono
quello che non viene consumato da
saprofagi vien ed è composto da funghi
batteri muffe e vari microrganismi
queste creature trasformano le sostanze
organiche in composti minerali e altre
sostanze organiche indispensabili per
far ripartire il ciclo biologico in
natura non esistono rifiuti come ben sa
lo scarabeo stercorario testimonia il
dolore del motto latino
de gustibus quello che può essere di
scarto per una creatura può essere una
prelibatezza per un'altra
l'uomo sapiens sapiens a dispetto del
suo nome altisonante è l'unica specie
sulla terra a produrre scarti non
riciclabili i rifiuti sono il risultato
di processi di produzione sbagliati
quelli adottati dalle nostre industrie
appunto ma abbiamo imparato a fare la
raccolta differenziata per riciclare no
il trend in italia è in crescita del 3
per cento
bene direte voi peccato che anche i
tempi di stoccaggio si siano allungati
del 18 per cento
e peccato che il 5 per cento dei rifiuti
rimanga non trattato
salvo poi finire in fumo in incendi più
o meno casuali
questo sistema produttivo può essere
definito come von credo tu grace ovvero
dalla culla alla tomba
questo paradigma decisamente molto poco
intelligente consiste nel prendere le
risorse dal pianeta usarle per costruire
oggetti da buttare via quando non ne
abbiamo più bisogno
togliamo poi ad estrarre nuove risorse
dal pianeta per sostituire quelle
accumulato nelle discariche ma esiste un
paradigma diverso
che imiti il funzionamento della natura
certo nel 2002 mcdonough e braungart lo
hanno descritto in questo saggio grado
ducato ovvero dalla culla alla culla non
basta limitare l'aggressione agli
ecosistemi per ritardare l'esaurimento
delle risorse con tecniche di produzione
meno intense consumi ridotti e
riciclaggio dei rifiuti
abbiamo bisogno di una soluzione poco
efficace occorre cambiare metodo
produttivo evitando la natura in modo da
poter reinserire i materiali usati in
successivi cicli produttivi all'infinito
si tratta di passare da un sistema di
produzione lineare ovvero prendo
costruisco utilizzo butto via quindi
inquino a1 circolare che i miti
funzionamento della natura e ricicli
costantemente il 100 per cento di ciò
che viene prodotto
l'obiettivo dell'economia crothall
crothall è quello di trasformare la
nostra impronta ambientale da negativa
in positiva passando dall eco efficienza
del recycling all'eco efficacia dell'aps
ai clan
occorre limitare i sistemi naturali
producendo senza alcuno scatto oggetti
facilmente teese assemblabili e
riciclati bello in teoria no ma esistono
veramente aziende che producono articoli
istituti si possono comprare e nel caso
come faccio a sapere che sto comprando
un articolo stituti per produrre un
articolo credo tu crothall debbo
registra mi sulla piattaforma on line
asti to see e fa controllare il mio
prodotto e parametri che verranno
controllati staranno la composizione
chimica dei materiali la loro
possibilità di utilizzo su e tecnici e
di compostaggio se organici la
provenienza di energie da fonti
rinnovabili l'utilizzo responsabile
dell'acqua e soprattutto l'assenza di
sfruttamento dei lavoratori
ognuno di questi cinque parametri verrà
valutato con un livello base bronzo
argento oro e platino e la valutazione
complessiva del prodotto
dipenderà dal valore più basso ottenuto
in una qualsiasi delle aree controllate
una volta certificato e mio prodotto
potrà essere inserito nel catalogo
online sito si è messo in vendita potrà
rilasciare certificazioni e consulenze
alle ditte interessate alle
certificazioni stesse e progetto credo
tu grado il dice annualmente concorsi di
progettazione di articolisti to see
mettendo a disposizione corsi
preparatori una lista dei materiale già
certificati istituti e software di
progettazione online questa pila che
vedete qui ad esempio ha vinto il premio
per miglior design del 2018 è facilmente
disassemblabile le componenti sono o
riciclabili come dischetti di metalli
feltrini in lana o compostabili come
biopolimero del contenitore questa pila
ricaricabile a di tua in una soluzione
di sale e aceto per ora è solo un
prototipo ma promette di risolvere un
problema molto importante come quello
della gestione delle pile esauste
adesso vi dirò qualcosa che vi lascerà
veramente senza parole nel 2013 cioè ben
sei anni fa una nota ditta di
abbigliamento sportivo aveva lanciato
ben otto linee di prodotti tutti i
certificati istituti fra cui le scarpe
la giacca e lo zaino che vedete in
figura
ecco cosa succedeva la scarpa
opportunamente trattata dopo sei
settimane e dopo sei mesi era
completamente compostabili perché tutti
i materiali con cui era stata prodotta
stoffa fili per le voci toure eccetera
erano organici quindi atossici la ditta
aveva ottenuto la certificazione e
lanciato questi prodotti sul mercato e
cosa è successo
sono rimasti invenduti sugli scaffali e
la ditta è stata costretta a ritirarli
dal commercio
tornando a produrre gli articoli che
creano rifiuti certo che consumatori
poco informati possono fare danni per
fortuna nonostante questo esperimento
finito male
in europa abbiamo più di 170 aziende che
ad oggi producono articoli tradotto
crothall in italia ce ne sono cinque e
producono materiali da costruzione e
tessuti
la difficoltà più grande nel mettere su
una filiera di tipo crothall to grado è
di trovare qualcuno che ti fornisca
materiali certificati quindi più aziende
decideranno di convertirsi al paradigma
sito si più sarà facile per altre
cambiare modo di produrre è un processo
esponenziale i prodotti sito si inoltre
non hanno nulla da invidiare rispetto ai
prodotti normali anzi a volte costano
addirittura di meno guardate che belle
queste t shirt lanciate due anni fa sono
composti interamente di cotone organico
e sono colorate utilizzando solo
coloranti naturali atossici quindi sono
compostabili in sicurezza
e questi sono dei jeans certificati sito
si i prodotti istituti che esistono
dobbiamo renderci conto che moltissimo è
nelle mani di noi consumatori siamo noi
a decidere se premiare le aziende che
continuano ad inquinare o quelle che
stanno cercando di cambiare modo di
produrre noi come consumatori abbiamo in
mano il futuro del mondo cassiano
[Musica]
bravo
[Applauso]
[Musica]